[Music]
that there's always been a rainbow
hanging over your head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sunday's episode of american idol
brought the waterworks as contestant sam
fenelli faced his fears and auditioned
for judges katy perry lionel richie and
luke bryan this
is american idol the 28 year old who
works in a bakery opened up about his
struggles with autism revealing how
music helped him get through a difficult
childhood
i don't connect with people very well
it's just a small it's just a small part
of who i am it's not all of who i am so
it was lonely growing up but music was
like my best friend and when it came
time to sing for the judges he admitted
that aside from doing a little bit of
karaoke he had never really sang in
front of people something katy perry
actually teased to et when they were
filming the auditions in the fall
there's been a few people that have even
tried out
in this season it's going to be amazing
to see their journey because some of
them they've never sang in public you
can see that there is a diamond there
and it's just going to take a lot of
mining a lot of mentoring a lot of just
like kid gloves just like you know
do you trust us we want the best for you
and that's i think that's our motto for
all of our time here on american idol is
we really want to see these kids shine
and shine sam did singing casey
musgraves inspiring track rainbow
[Music]
yeah that performance had all three
judges on their feet with tears in their
eyes
you told us about your struggle
and now you walk out here after no other
experience to american idol
and you have three judges
giving you a standing ovation sam
you were born enough
and your what we consider your handicap
is your gift
you understand me you are enough
okay
katie you want to just kind of take
charge here because i'm about to just
break down like
same lionel
same
having a kid stand in front of you and
you know they're nervous and you know
what that feels like and you know they
want to be a star and you know what that
feels like and so i'm really imparting
wisdom
that i love because
when i see them i'm not looking at them
as a contestant i'm looking at it as
myself
but did the judges decide to send the 28
year old singer through to the next
round in hollywood
you ready for this
my first words are
yes
[Music]
i don't want to send them to hollywood
if unless i really think they're going
to get in there and compete so i've been
a little tougher this year
after that sweet moment sam called his
audition the happiest day of his life on
instagram
sharing this snap of his golden ticket
alongside the caption hey y'all i made
it adding quote i hope to inspire people
to chase their dreams no matter what
challenges they may be facing
are you ready to be the next kelly
clarkson
i'm gonna sure as hell try
as for all the other idol hopefuls the
show's host ryan seacrest as well as
katie luke and lionel dished their best
advice to e.t be authentic and be candid
and if you're nervous tell them and if
you uh
think that you have screwed up tell them
you've screwed up and start over go in
with a confidence but not with an
arrogance over singing is a big deal and
it really kind of
almost goes the other way it shows that
they're lacking in some confidence on
some other stuff what we're looking for
is someone who has that instant identity
and a lot of times they'll come in and
say i sing everything i see i do
everything well i know you sing
everything but what is it to do for your
character who is the character of your
of your star i personally think it's
attitude when you come in and you think
you know everything and
you're unteachable
there's a lot of sifting to do but we
can see those diamonds in the rough
[Music]
you